. Let's go next to let's try the seven seven
four area code sticking again, potentially
with Massachusetts, who's calling today from
774.
Hi, is this me?
Yes, it is.
Hi, David.
I'm Trevor from Wister.
Trevor, what's going on?
So I would just want to ask you about Biden's
environmental plan.
Yeah.
He put a bunch of different cool, not cool,
but very progressive pieces into his policy.
Like he was saying, the environmental and
climate division in the DOJ and overhauling
the EPA, external civil rights compliance
office and creating a national crisis strategy
and all that stuff.
But what did Biden, in your opinion, leave
out of his plan that maybe the progressives
in his unity group wanted into the plan that
he left out?
You know, you'd have to ask them.
I've only looked at a bulleted summary so
far.
I've not read through all of it.
But certainly the Biden plan is not the green
New Deal.
The Biden plan is, you know, what I found
good about the Biden plan in terms of the
summaries that I've read, is that he's doing
what he promised to do.
In other words, months ago, Joe Biden said,
I support the Green New Deal as a framework
with which I will build a plan and we'll listen
to what the Green New Deal says and consider
other voices and a lot of people that I don't
believe it.
I don't believe it.
And the Biden plan integrates some of the
milestones and guidelines of the Green New
Deal into a plan that, to be clear, is not
the green New Deal.
But what I'm pleased by is that, first of
all, I mean, listen, again, Biden is not an
ultra progressive if Biden gets to do what
he's proposing.
It will be the most progressive environmental
plan in the history of the United States.
Now you're going to have people who come out
and say he'll never get it done.
Well, that's not unique to Biden.
No president gets everything done that they
say they want to do.
You'll hear people come out and say, Biden
doesn't really believe this stuff.
He's only saying it because he thinks it will
help him politically.
You can say that about any candidate.
And to some degree, it's always true.
But the idea that Biden is particularly dishonest
about what he wants.
I've seen no evidence for.
So listen up.
If I do a full review, I could come back to
you and say, here's the five things that aren't
in it that should be.
But overall, I like that Biden has stuck to
his word of using the Green New Deal as a
framework for putting together a plan.
I'm pleased with it.
Fellow Trevor from I'm sorry I missed that
last part.
I'm sorry.
I'm pleased overall that Joe Biden has stuck
to his word and used the Green New Deal as
a framework for his plan.
Yes, I agree completely that the Green New
Deal is a great framework, it should be what
we have.
But this is definitely a great alternative.
My second question really quickly would be,
do we need the Electoral College in order
or rather in order to implement rank choice
voting into our voting system?
Do we need the Electoral College or can we.
Should we get rid of it in order to implement
rank choice?
You can do.
Then we surveyed ungulate pipes.
It's really two separate things.
I mean, listen, if you go to national popular
vote, you eliminate electors per state and
you can tally the national popular vote as
first past the post or ranked choice voting,
single transferable vote, et cetera.
There'd be one path.
The other path is you keep the Electoral College.
But at the individual state level, the elections
are held using a ranked choice or alternative
voting system.
So there's a lot of people talk about doing
both together.
Obviously, it's incredibly unlikely that you're
going to get both together nationally at the
exact same time, but they don't have to both
be done together.
OK, awesome.
Thanks for answering my questions.
All right, Trevor, thank you so much for the
phone call.
I very much appreciate it.